of us will be getting out of the house
this summer and enjoying the great
outdoors
and with lake mead in our backyard you
don't have to go too far
take a look
last season on the lake we went
wakeboarding we went jet skiing we
explored
secret coves and today we're going
fishing
hey bruce hey jc how you doing got your
rod for you a child's rod this is
perfect
what kind of uh what kind of boat we're
going out so last time we took out that
400 halite yes
today we're gonna upgrade a little bit
we're gonna take the 1985 boston whaler
what that that's absolutely perfect this
is gonna be an amazing day
so when this boat came off the factory
line ronald reagan was the president as
he was but there's
a cool backstory on it though yeah so
we're we're actually a boston whaler
dealer this is a 1985 boston whaler
originally was sold as a fishing boat to
a fishing guide
and it's not a work boat for us but we
were the very first boston wheeler
dealer
my grandparents were in 1958 or 59
on the west coast
[Music]
we made it las vegas bay now now bruce
this is i was inside your bait shop and
this one this
this lower color for laura caught my eye
if it caught your eye it's gonna catch
fish's eyes
exactly so can we put that one on on
this this rod here let's do it let me
grab it and grab your finger perfect
i read something that fish they actually
can they can smell stuff yeah it's the
fact that our
our hands and our scent is now all over
that lure that might um
we rubbed our hands and anchovies to
start so that's the trick
and there's the switch right yeah so
flip the switch
here bring it back to you and then if
you hold your finger just like you got
it yeah
and then open it up oh that's the gopro
in the water
i'll go in and get it this is the life
fishing the lake
when it comes to speed does it matter i
think you come in real slow
and just lure that fish in no pun
intended
i think the fish are laughing i said we
dropped the gopro in the water probably
i was looking online doing some research
okay and it said when it comes to
fishing
las vegas bay which is where we are
prime time is like four five
six o'clock in the morning yeah yeah
yeah we're like uh four or five o'clock
at night yeah based on the sun this is
this is high noon right now yeah not
looking good yeah
don't lose bearing on our gopro now does
the engine scare the fish
absolutely if you're watching right now
the trick is to take note as to what
bruce and i are doing and do the
complete opposition
you roll up i'm screaming i don't know
why scaring all the fish
oh yeah it's on now this this is a
classic shakespeare fishing rod this is
that i had a shakespeare's again yeah
yeah
this is the spider-man version here we
go this one's very simple push the
button
hold the button look at that
throw and there you go that's it look at
that right there look
bruce caught something yeah we're eating
a stick for dinner tonight
it's operation rescue gopro time
do you have a net or anything no
we're not real fisherman
[Music]
let's recap photographer lance broke his
headphones we lost a gopro in the lake
and bruce we didn't catch any fish but i
tell you what it still was an amazing
afternoon yeah we had a great day but
you know what we appreciate having you
down so we got some fish and chips in
the boathouse for you here let's do it
all right
great awesome is this uh work as a shirt
absolutely you're perfect come on in
it was such a fun afternoon and if you
want to try your luck at fishing or any
other
lake activities go to
boatinglakemead.com rocky we never found
that gopro
yeah wow i saw the mud and i also saw
you with no shirt
okay hey with